Oh
[Music]
do you have oh you have to breathe this
is wonderful cheese you ever had in your
life yes yes yes that is Meryl Streep as
Julia Child and the scene from 2009's
Julie and Julia that passion for cheese
is something many of us share but some
have an appetite to learn even more
about it and for those there may be no
better place than Murray's cheese here
in New York City it's been around for
almost 80 years growing from a local
cheese shop to store restaurant even a
classroom one of its most popular
classes in recent years cheese boot camp
a weekend long session where students
devour up to 45 different varieties of
cheese and that's just one part of it we
tagged along for the most recent session
which included two students from an
unexpected place it's really the only
thing that we knew about making cheese
was that you make it from milk yeah
littering that was the only thing we
knew Christina badou and Gordon Dempster
were just college students in Jamaica
when their love for imported artisan
cheeses turned from a passion to a
purpose we didn't even have a plan I
said this makes you notice I said yes no
one was making cheese in Jamaica and we
had all this milk from these goats and
colors and everything and no one was
doing anything with it so we just
thought it's just go ahead and make
cheese because we love cheese so much
sounds like a good idea but how do you
figure out how to make cheese then well
I had a difficult learning curve in the
beginning because I'm we're making a
read about cheetahs they're using the
Internet to decide and to learn and so
in the beginning was really challenging
yeah four years later Christina and
Gordon's impromptu idea is now a growing
business they own and operate their own
artisan cheese brand Outland herders
Creamery and farmstead what's the idea
behind the business development we want
to show that Jamaica is not just you
know what that's for me you know jerk
chicken or reagan new zingers we're also
good with cheese and you know in some
way help lifter Rico that's a tiny
country but with thousands of varieties
on the market making the cut takes more
than making a decent wheel
so Cristina and Gordon made the trip
here to Marie's cheese in New York City
to take part in a highly coveted
three-day intensive course known as
cheese bootcamp we offer the class four
times a year and we only have 24 seats
available in each session so about a
hundred people a year get to come
through the doors Elisabeth Chubbuck is
the senior vice president of sales for
Maurice she says the bootcamp started as
a six-week course in 2006 the result of
customer demand people coming into our
classrooms and saying we want more than
just a wine and cheese pairing class we
want more than just a cheese 101 so how
do we how do we learn to do what you
guys do so it wasn't enough to just eat
the cheese people just wanted to know
more they wanted to know where it came
from they wanted to know how it was made
they wanted to know what made it special
boot camp students come from all over I
have a cheese shop in Brazil and for
different reasons I'm a pastry chef and
I foresee cheese's gonna be in my future
in a big way they had an HR for a
financial services company so nothing to
do with cheese but I'm hoping that
cheese could be the next chapter I'm
just a cheese fanatic and here to to
learn hopefully every single one of us
in this room already shares by default
is our love of cheese the students are
taught by an American cheese Society
certified cheese professional who begins
bootcamp with a lesson in history and
geography we're going to start let's say
8,000 BC on the second day there's a
field trip to Maurice cheese caves in
Long Island City one of the biggest
draws for those looking to further their
education before they can even enter the
students have to complete a chemistry
course on milk once sanitized and suited
up the group is guided through the aging
process known as Athena's it takes place
in the caves which are monitored 24/7
for specific humidity and temperature on
the final day of boot camp glasses of
wine and beer are poured for pairings
classes taught by industry experts
and students are put to the test when it
comes to slicing and rapping different
styles of cheese all skills it takes to
become what's known as a cheese monger
at Murray's Cielo Peralta is quite
literally the Big Cheese among them now
we go back to Spain okay you like a
manchego right you love it it's a bar
with a little small so does that mean
it's younger than John getting glue
Lukey what just like you oh thank you he
can walk a customer through the more
than 300 international cheeses that are
in the front case at Murray's a case
which one day Christina and Gordon hope
will have one of their Jamaican cheese's
when you talk about making cheese you
don't want it to just stay in Jamaica no
you want to offer it to the world yeah
wherever the cheese actually comes from
it it's just so close to the land the
identity you can't separate the cheese
from where it is from you know it
transforms you to a different place and
it takes you there through the flavor of
the cheese so we want to be able to
represent Jamaica through a piece of
cheese which is crazy to just think
about as it is but also magical to
imagine that a piece of cheese can
transform you to to Jamaica or anywhere
else and as we as we get to enjoy some
broad free samples my brain yeah well
and Emily our producer on it certainly
did from Murray's I have to say this the
Jamaican cheese is that these two are
making there's a false banana cheese
it's made in a banana leaf it's a brief
style with fruity notes a Jamaican Jerk
cheese has roasted Mentos and even a
Jamaican chocolate and coffee infused
type of cheese it's amazing when you
think about it what they said it
transports you to a different place so
why wouldn't we want cheeses from other
parts not just a France or in England or
here this is the one thing that could
make me go back to school
I pick the right day to fill in yes you
know I'm thinking now maybe we get a
cheese plate every show huh that'd be
nice